hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to would you rather I
shouldn't need to explain it but in case
I do you pick one or the other and then
you live with that decision for the rest
of your life and everyone judges you for
as long as you live so let's get to it
would you rather be a genius in a world
of unintelligent people or be
unintelligent in a world of geniuses now
this is a little bit of a dilemma
because they say ignorance is bliss but
at the same time if you were a genius in
a world full of unintelligent people
that would be extremely annoying
fine you could also maybe possibly
control them I would love to see like
how far society went if the entire world
was filled with idiots now no one gets
sassy down in the comments the world is
not filled with idiots there's a lot of
idiots but it's not filled to the brim
with them like every other person was an
idiot I think it'd be really cool to be
a genius in that world because then you
could manipulate them - you will and
Bend them and be a horrible dictator
that controls over everybody and then
again a seemingly good evil again but
that's one that I'd pick so there we go
and everyone else agrees with me so
everyone else wants to be a horrible
dictator as well hmm would you rather be
stabbed in the stomach ten times or be
shot in both kneecaps oh my god this is
not good well if you're stabbed in the
stomach for ten times are you even gonna
survive that like would you even survive
like if the stomach is a general region
like directly in the stomach acid
spilling out of your stomach would
probably not be very good for you and
all the blood loss from ten stab wounds
but if you're shot in both kneecaps and
that kind of cripples you for life and
you probably won't ever be able to walk
again but then again the the age of
prosthetics is getting a little better I
could have robot legs fusion-powered
robot leg sounds pretty good to me so
maybe I'll go with that one higher
chance to survive now that's a split
decision I don't know what you guys
would pick
Wow
would you rather be known as a racist or
be known as a sexist okay so this is a
trap if I pick one that makes me the
other doesn't it isn't the way this work
if I if I say I'd rather be a racist
then that's like isn't this little this
little incriminating here I don't want
to be saying like this okay would you
rather be known as a racist or be known
as a sexist oh god I can't escape this
one you got a pic I don't like oh man
what do you guys think I have no idea
what would oh man
okay so if you're known as a racist then
you're hated by okay if we're looking
completely logically if you're looking
at it completely logically let's say
you're only racist against one race
let's say statistically one race so it's
a certain subset of the population but
not half if you're sexist then an entire
half of the population doesn't like you
so if I'm going by statistics I would
rather be a raisin because what people
would hate me oh it sounds so horrible
but it's the only way that I could
rationalize it how would you do it I
don't know I don't want to be either
bassist y'all got it wrong huh
no no no oh no no I'm not racist I'm not
sexist I promise I promise
Oh would you rather take the cinnamon
challenge or take the gallon challenge
given that I have taken the cinnamon
challenge before and I'll even link you
can see there's a video down there of me
blowing up a boo hit and you can watch
the video down there it's when I hit a
thousand subscribers on my channel for
the first time it was really an amazing
milestone and I was really happy about
it but the cinnamon challenge oh I would
never do that again
so I gotta go with a gallon challenge
even though that makes you throw up at
least throwing up isn't the same as
having your entire esophagus burning
from cinnamon and your windpipe and
everything in fact so I got to go with
oh really
really well I guess if you know what
you're doing on the cinnamon challenge
then you would be able to do it properly
because I didn't do it properly I tried
to all shove it down my throat I tried
to work it down as fast as possible what
you need to do is you need to put it in
like cheek or something and then let
your saliva kind of not make it so
terrible but you only have a minute in
the appropriate cinnamon challenge you
only have a minute so would you rather
be extremely paranoid
or be extremely naive so no no rampant
paranoia is not a good feeling like it's
not a good feeling to have it all times
but if you're extremely naive then you
fall for a lot of things in you're very
gullible and then also leads you into
certain situations if you're paranoid at
least you're cautious like it's not a
good feeling hat but at least you're
cautious about everything but maybe to
an extreme I guess I'd rather be happy
and naive than nervously paranoid the
entire time yeah that's a split decision
what would you guys pick oh my god oh
hey oh look at this would you rather
have two million YouTube subscribers or
1 million Twitter followers
obviously the YouTube subscribers
because that's doesn't that's like more
worthy you're putting up videos for
people's entertainment if you have a
million Twitter followers that's just
for your ego plus it's a job when you're
on YouTube if you're on Twitter that's
not a job alright I gotta go and you do
I think everyone agrees with me would
you rather prevent 9/11 or prevent the
death of three people you choose our
didn't need oh my goodness well given
that more people died on 9/11 but also
prevent the death of three people you
choose so if there was ever a moment in
time I guess in my lifetime where there
was someone very important that diamond
shouldn't have died oh man that would be
tough cuz I'm assuming it means that I'm
just saving them from dying and then
they'll die later imagining this doesn't
mean I choose to save him and live
forever so
I don't know who I pick off the top of
my head so I gotta go with prevent 9 oh
god of course I would prevent 9/11 it
wouldn't stop so many other chain events
coming after 9/11 okay so I guess I
gotta go with that one because Wow
totally a hundred percent split on that
one fifty-fifty Wow
but you know of any that's only under
the assumption that it means that I
can't I it's only in my timeline that I
can pick people not to die and then they
wouldn't live forever it's just you know
maybe if it was if it was a live forever
two kind of thing afterwards then I
would have to go with the three people
cuz I can pick three people that would
be able to live forever
well that'd be sad for them I don't know
it's hard would you rather be slapped
full force by a UFC fighter or forced to
lick a dog turd oh I mean if it's a slap
I've been slapped before but full force
slap would be pretty rough but even from
a UFC fighter wouldn't be deadly if
you're like a dog turd Hey
bacteria are becoming more you know
resilient antibiotics what if you get a
horrible disease from that it's not
gonna be so good anymore I can live with
a slap
I could live with a slap uh I'm gonna go
with the fighter thank you very much yes
I don't want to lick any dog turds would
you rather have 300 horses or have a car
with 300 horsepower 300 horsepower
that's not even that much that's like
that's not that much right I don't know
much about cars but I hear about cars
that have 800 horsepower all the time
I'd rather have 300 horses because that
means I have a horse for 300 horses that
would be amazing
I can breed horses for the rest of my
life yeah I doesn't sound very fun that
does it not sound very fun but hey at
least I could sell them I could eat them
they can eat the horses that's what I'd
do Oh what why is is having a car with
300 horsepower really that special I
don't know cars I don't know but if you
have 300 horses one that's awesome to
like you gonna form you how you can or Z
race them I don't know what you do with
what do you do with
right him I guess you could charge into
battle to get out get 300 of your
friends reenact 300 except this time
they have horses 300 part to the 300
inning with horses and then crush them
all I don't know where I'm going with
this would you rather have a large
painting of yourself or a life-size
sculpture of yourself oh I gotta go with
the sculpture that sounds so cool wait
am i naked in this am i naked in either
of these most sculptures I see they're
naked so I don't know if I want that but
maybe the large painting of myself like
how large we talking about like the end
of tutors when the King had the huge
floor-to-ceiling painting of himself I
mean those lasts longer I think
know what I mean statues they kind of
erode over time so the paintings they
can be kept preserved for a long time
gotta go with the painting
oh really some egotistical x' here not a
knobby if the whole thing was a you
distal would you rather steal an out of
elderly woman's purse or tell ten
orphans that Christmas is canceled oh
that's so sad and Christmas is right
around the corner oh I'd rather steal an
old lady's purse I can't believe I have
to say that out loud I would rather
steal an old lady's purse oh but what if
it's not really cancelled what if it's
oh it's just a prank hi you orphans
thought Christmases problem hey come on
it's just a prank bro it's just a prank
okay I'm gonna go in the elderly Wow
hahaha I can give it back I guess oh
it's so sad would you rather be Napoleon
or to be Julius Caesar's well here come
the short jokes I can already tell
people are crying it out well are you
sure - boy huh but you rather be that
huh
Oh
perfectly normal at four foot seven
let's go see let's go to bolian all
right would you rather always know when
people are lying or always get away with
lying I can't remember if this sounds
familiar but man if I could always get
away with lying that I could literally
say anything I want to anyone and they
would believe me now that does that's
not saying that I could be very
convincing about what I'm saying in my
life
like if I always get away with lying no
matter what that seems much more useful
than knowing when other people are lying
is if you're trained you can spot lies
pretty easily like it's not that often
that you don't know someone's lying
unless they're really being sneaky about
it but always getting away with lying
that's such a better skill really oh but
why would the other one be useful I
don't know why the other one would be
useful I mean of course it'd be used
where you always know when people are
lying but still like get away with so
much get away with so much oh boy
would you rather stand on red-hot
burning coals for thirty seconds without
moving or shut your hand in a waffle
iron for two minutes oh oh oh God I'm
gonna leave that one to you because I
don't think I can answer that one that
one is bad oh that is bad the whole that
is bad oh that is bad so which one would
you rather choose guys I hope you can
make a decision because I sure can
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want another one of
these let me know down in the comments
below and also answer this question for
me in any other the questions down
Thank You everybody again and as always
I will see you in the next video every
sentence with a racial epithet